émond à l'hiver tu es un des tenants de
la tradition est d'ailleurs tu as publié
un livre qui est une sorte de bible il
faut bien le dire c'est bien gentil à
toi venir cela qui a d'ailleurs un
succès prodigieux que tu viens de vendre
aux américains c'est exagère vient
d'amérique j'en ai parlé en fait des
états unis plus exactement
effectivement nous avons vendu un
certain nombre bon alors je suis
d'autant plus surpris de voir que tu
viens de me un livre qui s'appelle
cuisine insolite alors qu'au moment des
fêtes là tu pourrais peut-être nous
indiquer une de ses recettes insolites
caisse la rue à la sur ton sur ton à
choir la lola 7 la bosse du chameau à
explique nous sert alors le charme au
comme tu le sais à des parties
comestibles et d'autres qui le sont
moins
alors le meilleur morceau c'est la
beauce alors ça c'est le sommet de la
poste du chameau ne faut pas un chameau
adulte ou un il faut cependant chameau
jeune femelle si possible d'ailleurs
trois ans cinq ans à peu près alors
yahia cuisse qui est excellente mais la
peau c'est évidemment ce qu'elle meyer
alors c'est la poste dont nous allons
parler un métal et par quoi elle est
retenue il ya le lard le lard qui
intervient n'est pas le lard de poitrine
qui vient que qui vient pour une partie
il ya l'huile l'huile de coton n'est
entendu mille qu'il s'agit de charmants
alors je vais naturellement couper des
lardons
genivi a lardé dans le servir lavalard
alors on la cendre un tout petit peu
comme ceci de façon à pouvoir passer à
l'intérieur de la boîte comme ceci alors
dans une chambre voilà qui est fait et
puis on boucle lardons dans le central
comme ceci la voilà et puis on va le
faire rentrer à l'intérieur c'est du
lard d'antilopes nom a bien subi la
question d'autre chose
alors évidemment ça à feu très doux
pendant une heure et demie minimum mais
c'est beaucoup mieux si on dépasse 7
heures alors là évidemment va me faire
le reproche c'est pas vous qui payez le
gaz c'est en général ce que l'on me dit
bien sûr ce n'est pas moi qui fais le
gall n'a pas aussi le circuit de charbon
de bois
c'est ça que c'est sa polo gris toujours
on passe toujours à payer le compteur du
gardien en réalité le charbon de bois
marthe rivière
on ne peut pas faire une sauce aux seins
tout de même ah si si si si important il
faut pas oublier que le vin le vin était
égyptien alors à l'origine je croyais
pour le chameau sobriété et et sentent
également il y avait effectivement là
une question que le foyer dispute
effectivement le chameau est réputé pour
sa sobriété mais cette sobriété je crois
et dans la cadence à laquelle ils voient
ils voient rarement mais il voit
beaucoup cette caméra
[Musique]